statement from the man who is  stands accused of spreading the corona  virus some people call him  the super spreader he's been identified  or identified himself as  steve walsh and he's put out a statement  saying  i would like to thank the nhs for their  help and care  whilst i have fully recovered my  thoughts are with others who have  contracted the coronavirus  as soon as i knew i had been exposed  to a confirmed case of coronavirus i  contacted my gp  nhs 111 and public health england i was  advised to attend an isolated  room at hospital despite showing no  symptoms and subsequently self-isolated  at home as instructed  when the diagnosis was confirmed i was  sent to an isolation unit at a hospital  where i remain and as a precaution my  family was  also asked to isolate themselves  that statement from steve walsh some  call the super spreader  you